the jurogan experience i know you
exercise a lot you used to be german i
know i i know you used to be giants i
was 40 pounds bigger than i oh my god
literally what what made you get so
jacked i got the flu and then i just
know what you
yeah um i just uh
well i'll tell you what i did but it was
when i got that permanent gig i had
nothing to do all day in vegas literally
i just started getting so i started just
going to the gym every day like i'd go
three hours a day literally three hours
of lifting yeah well this is again 15
years ago right and i was i i just was
huge and one day i went to my warehouse
to do something it was a picture of
something
and i was like what the [ __ ] like i'm
like i was like one 90 i'm like 140.
why this is my this is my original
fighting weight right now
140 is my it's my uh that's how you feel
yeah this is where i grew up born and
raised 135 140 my whole life and then i
went to like 185 people like what did
you have a lot of joint pain all the
time yeah everything i was always
injured i was always hurt yeah didn't
look good on stage it was just it was
weird it's like you know people like
what the [ __ ] happened to karen tom
they've always said that
but that is a thing though when you get
really jacked on stage it becomes a
distraction it did yeah it did yeah yeah
gene simmons of all people came says uh
does does being so muscular take away
from the uh the uh that's the worst
so i got gene really good one time said
this is great so he comes back him to
show comes backstage and he said he says
to me
um what do you do
to make money besides
this and i said what the [ __ ] it done
nothing he said you don't have any other
things that
gives you money i said i don't i don't
know i do comedy six nights a week but
you don't have another investment of
some sort yes he's trying to offer you
some prostitution well no yeah
they're really weird
and uh gene listen i'm seeing somebody
okay
buddy um
uh let me try on your platforms no so i
uh
but he says to me and this is great
because i'm being i'm being like really
serious with him right so i said uh well
i said no but i i i did one thing a long
time ago i i wrote a jingle um
he what's the jingle and i said it's a
by menon and he says
i'm not following you i say remember the
commercial by menon
and he goes
that was you and i said yeah he says
get the [ __ ] i said no i said my friend
has a had a organ in in my garage he had
left there and we were out [ __ ]
around and this that that by men and
thing had a
campaign that said come up with a jingle
so we did we came up with it just
wasn't even funny which is by men and
and we sent it to
the men in whatever that was it under
whatever yep and uh he says wait a
second so that you did that's you're
making this up i said no
he's how much did they pay for that i
said i'm still i still get money for it
i said it was amazing but it just kind
of a fluke i said we tried to come up
with other things
and he's looking at me like that is just
unremarkable and i said yes
[Laughter]
and then he said i said uh auntie that's
great and i said anything else i said
well i came up with with now with retzen
and he says what are you talking about i
said with retson remember the search and
he goes you're [ __ ] me i said yes he
goes but the men and thing i said no
it's all [ __ ] he lost
he lost his [ __ ] he's like god damn it i
sat there for 20 minutes i believing you
came up with by men
and rhett
i said no i'd never but i got him good
on his show
because i did i did that when he had it
at his house that that uh
oh the reality show yeah yeah so family
first met him i i go family jewels and i
go and i i'm he says
my impression uh you want to see my uh
my warehouse and i said sure so it takes
me to this huge
wing of his house
i mean literally it's probably the size
of
walmart it's full he says me i've got
i've got everything asked i said well of
course you have a kiss condom i mean he
goes oh yeah yeah yeah we're good yeah
cause coffins we've kissed everything
you know and i said uh
i said uh
we're on we're live or they're filming
me with him and i said uh good towards
the end i said he said well thank you
for dropping by and i said i said i
don't want to this is going to come
across
completely [ __ ]
wrong i said don't take this the wrong
way and he says what i said you're going
to take this the wrong way he says what
i said
i've never heard of this your band you
must i said you must have done well
but i've never heard of kiss and he says
it's like a really weird because
you've never heard a kiss i said no i
see i knew you'd take it the wrong way i
said i just i i mean look at all this
holy [ __ ] i've never heard kiss are you
guys how long have you guys been a band
and he looked at me like
he's going to [ __ ] kill me and i said
i said i know like hanson i know a
handsomer
this is when they were hitting it big
you know i said i know hansen right and
he goes you [ __ ] me i said no i don't i
never heard of kiss
that's why i said i'm [ __ ] with you
come on jesus and then i got him again
and he was serious he like he really
believed you
oh yeah no
you